How long do you have to wait to take supplements before your blood work or
doesn't not matter? It doesn't really matter at all. So your supplements shouldn't
affect your blood work really at all. So when you're getting just a CBC or a
complete metabolic panel or you're getting full testing for food
sensitivities or anything, your supplements taking your supplements right before
you do your blood work. It literally has no effect on your blood work. I've
not seen anything about supplements that affect your blood work. So you don't
have to worry about that. The only thing I will say about blood work is that it's
always best to do it 12 hour fast. So I know sometimes that's just not
convenient. You're going in to get a blood test at four o'clock in the afternoon.
You would have fasted all day. A lot of the blood markers are fast. It really
makes no difference. It does make a difference on your glucose levels and some
other factors, some other markers as well. Definitely your glucose levels. Now
with the advent of home cominers and people that have a whole glucometer, you
know, your glucose level on your blood test on a CBC makes a little, you're
not really looking at that. Then if you're able to measure your own glucose levels
throughout the day and post eating and so it's not as make a deal. But typically it's
always better to do a 12 hour fast before you're doing any blood work. So you'd
want a schedule in a perfect case scenario schedule your blood work to go
in at nine o'clock or eight o'clock in the morning to get your blood work and you
haven't eaten since eight o'clock at night before. That's going to be your best
thing. That's going to be your best picture to get your blood work. The other good
thing to look at when you get blood work done is that you do it at the same time
each time you do it. So if you let's say you're getting blood work every month or
every three months or every six months, you try to schedule it at nine o'clock in the
morning every time you go to get your blood work done and you do a 12 hour fast
on each one. You're going to get just more accurate comparisons.